let's start with you jonathan pope is
related to denmark taney
the pogues were so close to walking away
with a cross
how did you feel about pope's journey
this season
yeah it was just um just you know from
the beginning of the season kind of like
seeing you know the story map of where
pope's story line was going to go this
year
i was i was i was always excited and i
was always ready for challenge you know
i relate a lot to what pope went through
personally i had a family member who was
taken from us through you know racism
you know he was he was he was like my
great-great-grandfather was lynched and
so i i definitely and that was k and
that was kept from me when i was a kid
and
and i didn't know until like i was like
i was about pope's age i was 16 when i
when like my grandmother
actually told me about it was like oh
well you got to be careful because now
that you're an adult business and i was
like
i was like oh like that's real like you
know
and i think pope kind of discovers that
this season and
you know where i didn't have a chance to
go find justice
he does and he has a thing he can look
for to get you know even if it's just
like even if it's money even if it's
like material
you have something there's something
there that feels like i'm getting back
i'm getting my justice
and that was just like fun to do this
season and and to explore and
to get like you know the from like the
range from the excitement of it to the
to the despair of learning the more you
learn the more the deeper you get the
more you have to care
thank you for sharing that i mean hey i
can't believe
that that happened but also in a way i'm
i'm
i love how they they did make that part
of this
this journey for pope will he in season
three
get that crossback will he get justice
i think i think pope will get justice i
don't know about the cross i don't know
about
all the specifics of you know the pogues
never seem to come out with anything
they go for
but they definitely come out with with
the feeling of winning and the justice
they do
you know like no bad guy comes out
unscarred
you know so we'll see uh
and then what about cleo and pope there
there seemed to be some
sparks flying there is she is she a
pogue
are things she's a pogo she's possible
all right i feel like i feel like she's
a pogue now you know like we'll see what
happens you know with moving forward
with the third season but that's
definitely
i feel like cleo was somebody pope
wishes he would like a little more just
like
the term more like she feels like you
know like she's she knows what she's
doing she's
she's confident in herself she's
confident in her abilities
and she's like she doesn't care what
other people think and you know i think
those
are attributes that open myers madison
rudy let's move on to you guys
i feel like kiara and jj
shared some really sweet moments this
season
especially at the end when jj
was drowning kiara's emotions really
came out
what did you make of what was going on
between them
this season i think this season i mean
really
kiara and pope are really trying to
figure out their thing
and i i don't know the emotions at the
end it could go one of two ways
like he's my best friend you know i
think
i think i would feel that heartache if
it was if it was sarah or john b
pogba of anyone you know like
yeah like in the end of the day all the
pogs
are basis of friends and i think jj
seeing what pope is dealing with and
like i think there would always be
a certain like kind of communication
there before
whatever and like uh and season three it
kind of sets up
whatever it might happen and i think
that
you know it's kind of crazy the timeline
of things that when you really put into
like perspective like there is not like
it's like
how long is season two guys like like
yeah it goes through it goes to the end
is
in the end of uh september i think right
like september 27th
no i mean like like like i mean like the
the timeline of like the series like
it's like like eight days it's like it's
like a month or something it's like a
month or two
a month no
a week's time like there's that's a
crazy amount of things that happen in
that much time and there needs to be
a ramp up of that so that's what that's
where i'm like
kind of feeling it's like the doors are
open at that point sure
um carla lambre is still out there
and plot twist john b's dad is still
alive
they're working together what did you
guys make when you read that
in the script
i couldn't believe it just like mine
i was like i was like the implications
of this
yeah i was like first of all is i'm like
is i'm like who's the good guy in this
situation because they both know each
other i was like what's going on
yeah like it was just so it it raised so
many questions for
for for especially for what it means for
pope and john b's relationship i think
you know like you know of course for
john b
himself of like holy crap my dad has
been alive this whole time i've been on
this whole crusade to avenge his death
and he's been here
alive and hasn't reached out you know
like it's
there's so many questions that like like
season three is like ready to answer
that i'm just like so excited for it
yeah that's what i was feeling when i
read it i was like like i need answers i
like i don't know everything
fans yeah going to feel after watching
yeah i feel
we feel like yeah this tomorrow there
are so many things that need to be
answered
yeah so many questions and i don't trust
don't be dead anymore i don't know about
you
i know i don't know yeah it's like all
of a sudden you're you're asking
yourself way too many you're like going
back and looking at the season like all
right his dad's here
these are there you're like you're it's
like questions on questions on questions
yeah exactly i am getting wrapped so
really quickly i want to each go around
and tell me um the number one thing that
you would like to see
in a potential season three yeah i want
to see
hope continue to you know figure out you
know the denmark candy connection and
how that relates to him and his family
and you know get some justice
okay i want to see how far jj will go to
risking his friend's safety and i'm
wondering if that's gonna be
the run and gun jj or that's gonna be
the more reserved and like hey maybe we
should take a step back
okay some development there yeah
um i want kiara to either make up with
her parents or get emancipated
i want i want something i'm curious
whether she's going to choose you know
like
make amends or boarding school guys
and start a new i'm interested